um
first item is acceptance of the minutes
of our march 28 2022
meeting
uh senator reagan moves to approve
second
uh
oh rep senator hennessy move seconds uh
any discussion all those in favor of
approval of the minutes signify by
saying aye aye
opposed nay the ice have it
uh new no old business new business
chapter
28-11
laws of 2017
colon transfers ca c p
22-08 department of administrative
services
request authorization to transfer 80 968
of appropriations from the completed
capital project doit new computer room
fire system chapter 28 1
roman 2 b 1 to capital project spalding
roof replacement chapter
228 1 2 b 3 as specified in the request
dated april 20th
2022 and is
will somebody
let let him speak for one moment
good morning committee my name is karen
rantamacki i'm the director of plant and
property
and i have with me ted copper
hi uh administrator for the division of
public works
um so we're requesting the transfer of
funds from one completed capital project
to a capital project that was recently
bid but does not have enough funds to
complete
um
and the the amount we're looking to
transfer is 80 968 dollars which is the
balance in the account
thank you and the remainder i
read will come out of your operating
budget correct
okay
now center the rig
yeah again
any questions of the department
uh senator reagan okay representative
bucco
thank you mr chairman i just was just
questioning what you just said about the
uh
the arrest of being covered by operating
funds that an additional 22 000. thank
you
okay
the
senator reagan moves approval of item
22-08
seconded by senator uh representative
mills
is there any discussion
seeing none all those favors signify by
saying aye
aye opposed nay
the eyes have it and the motion is
approved we have several informational
items
from department of transportation
environmental services
administrative services in the
university system of new hampshire
do any members of the committee have
questions about any of the informational
items
seeing none
we will move on to setting our next
meeting we will not be meeting over the
summer some people are going to be ready
for re-election
some people are going to be vacationing
or whatever
um
i would
long range is meeting
the morning of monday september 19th i
would propose that we meet at that same
day
it is
after
the primaries
after any recounts
and we have to factor those things in
obviously um so i would propose that we
meet at uh 10 15
the morning of september 19th
and then because we uh
the the current uh general court
dissolves in the first week in december
i i would propose that we plan on
meeting
monday november 28th
um
at 10 15 also and that november 28th
would be the last time
until at least february and maybe march
before a new committee is formed and can
meet
it
just the way things happen so
unless there is a serious objection
we will use those two
days and it's after general election and
all the rest and we finish up business
the week before we turn into pumpkins or
whatever happens to us
um
any
questions comments just
from members of the committee i thank
you all for coming for a very quick
meeting
um
some of you drove further than others
i appreciate you and representative
bucco as far
yeah thank you um
hopefully there will be others but i i
did not want to call it off because i
need to to be able to go forward with
that that one project uh at sp on
spalding um i would accept the motion to
adjourn
uh senator daniel smooth three adjourned
seconded by representative clutier all
those in favor signify by saying aye aye
bo snake the eyes have it i thank
everybody for attending